know you were listening along to that
interview with Jonathan Reynolds you of
course represent an awful lot of workers
in the energy sector what did you make
of his response when it comes to
blocking or North Sea oil and gas
licenses
well the firstly Sophie our Obsession
this week is not whether the factional
politics or indeed the politics of the
labor party my priority is listening to
our members this week the care workers
fighting for 15 pound to Noah the Amazon
workers fighting to get Union
recognition at their sites energy will
form part of the debate but I'm obsessed
with our members and looking after their
interests our members not about the
policies of Labor and on oil and gas
quite simply I think they would have
been naive they've got it wrong you know
we are critical Friends of the labor
party and I think there's just a lack of
intellectual rigor and thinking about
where they've got to on oil and gas
they're focusing on what they think is
popular rather than doing the proper
thinking to understand what is right for
the country
I promise I will get on to some of the
things that you're talking about at the
beginning there I apologize for the
order I've decided to do my questions in
but I do just want to ask a little bit
more about the oil and gas you say labor
being naive why do you think they're
being naive
because their their policies are going
to trade a cliff edge with oil and gas
instruct extraction from the North Sea
it's not going to be up to labor to
decide about investment in the future of
the North Sea the I I feel that
investment is going to dry up more
quickly than it should we are in a
process of manage decline in the north
shame we should be working together on
that but there is a lot of oil and gas
in the North Sea and the Alternatives
facing the country are that we either
produce our own oil and gas take
responsibility for our own carbon
emissions or we are going to import more
oil and gas and I think workers in the
petrochemical sector in grangemouth in
the Humber and teaside in pembrokeshire
and Folly I think they are going to be
very worried with what labor saying and
as I say it's time for labor daily to
focus on doing the right thing rather
than what they think is the popular
thing and you know our members in the
energy sector and the construction
sector aren't stupid
we've been promised tens of thousands of
jobs and Renewables but the truth is
those jobs have been created anywhere
but the UK our Renewables infrastructure
is getting built in China and Indonesia
anywhere really but Britain
I mean labors today are saying that they
will create half a million jobs through
their green energy plans you're a bit
skeptical of that then
well I I welcome this initiative I think
you know there's 13 years of failure
from the Tory government they've got us
in the whole on energy let's be clear
about that but working people in
Aberdeen and Humber and teaside and all
those areas that depend on the
petrochemical industry in energy
intensive manufacturing companies around
the country they are going to be worried
about the message from labor and I just
have to be honest with labor about that
we've been promised that we would be the
Saudi Arabia of renewals we'd be
promised time and time again that the
Renewables industry is going to create
all these jobs and they simply haven't
emerged there is a huge Wind Farm off
Brighton here where was that produced
where was all the steel and the wind and
the wind turbines fabricated it wasn't
in the UK and that has been the sorry
story of the Renewables industry around
the country labor should be focusing on
a plan for our energy future rather than
talking about bands Anatole Sophie I do
you know I would like to hear a label
politician now being very clear with the
Renewables industry that there'll be no
future developments for offshore auto
insurance until we actually get some
jobs and investment in a fabrication and
manufacturing jobs and working-class
communities because that's what they're
doing in America and I'd like to see
that replicated from labor
uh now a really interesting um points
that you make in the interviews so far
um you started off talking about the
priorities going into your conference in
Brighton and about pay in particular
we've of course seen lots of strikes in
the public sector
just how difficult are things for those
on low wages and how long do you think
this industrial action could go on for
as a result
we represent workers in both the public
and private sector and what I celebrate
because we'll never apologize for
workers standing up to defend their
standard of limit we celebrate the fact
that working people have come together
got organized under the union Banner to
campaign to defend their living
standards the Tories have got us into an
absolute whole economically inflation
going through the roof the economy
stagnating and working people are saying
we are not picking up the tab for the
Tory places we celebrate that fact we
welcome that fact and we're going to
talk about it over the coming days in
Brighton there'll be a tremendous energy
in this room the ambulance workers the
health workers the ones that Tori said
they wouldn't talk about to talk about
pay with well we forced them to talk
about pay and then I'll be speaking our
members in private care who's struggling
on you know earning pennies above the
minimum wage I'll be listening to them
about their demands for certain social
care and get into 15 pound an hour for a
minimum wage there
you obviously have members taking strike
action in the public sector but you've
also represented people who've seen
deals been struck I'm thinking
particularly of ambulance workers for
example in the NHS
do you think it is now time for unions
to start seriously accepting pay deals
with the government
well it's not just about government it's
where any employer I mean what we do as
a union the reason we're annoying our
Union finally and I understand it's
about any employer but I'm just
specifically asking about these public
sector pay deals for now if I may
well
we listen to our members I want the
minds are shaped by the priorities of
our members and it's not about the trade
unions moderating the demands it's about
the Tory part in moderating its behavior
in government and accepting that people
are struggling financially and people
want a decent pay raise you know we had
people who were on the front line of the
covet crisis and the uh the you know
these people want a decent pay raise and
absolutely deserve one
you were talking about Amazon workers of
course in ongoing dispute
do you think that as consumers we should
be shopping at Amazon
well Amazon the retail business is only
part of the company what concerns me is
that they provide a huge amount of
services to the public sector and if
they're not going to treat their workers
properly if they're not going to
recognize their employees rightful and
legitimate demand to have the GMB
recognized on their sites then there has
to be question marks about them getting
public sector contracts in future they
make a huge amount of their money from
what is almost at your a very powerful
position that they have are in providing
web services to the public sector and
that's going to have to be challenged as
well
now this morning The Observer on a
slightly different note you say that
politicians on all sides need to start
being honest about the effects of brexit
of course if you look at both parties
both labor and the conservatives they
say that the debates on brexit is over
they don't want to join the single
Market they don't want to join the
Customs Union
are you disappointed I guess by the
position of both labor and the
conservatives when it comes to brexit
look I think I travel all around the
country we've got members of length and
breadth of the UK and Ireland I
understand that you know brexit is not
going to be Revisited by the politicians
but there has to be an honest debate
about the impact that brexit has has had
it is part of the reason that we're
seeing the inflation that we've got
stuck in the economy it is having an
impact on investment in the UK and I
just think it needs to be an honesty
about that and looking forward to
policies around the future the defense
manufacturing and we talked about green
energy the UK is going to have to have
strong trading relationships with Europe
and indeed America and I think they're
going to have to be a reset of our
trading relationships with Europe and
America and we're going to have to
really start having that honest
conversations about the impact of brexit
on jobs and investment here in the UK
and just finally um Sky News has been
reporting this week on the latest
developments at Asda the owners of the
supermarket are going to buy their
sister company EG petrol forecourts but
the GMB has spoken out against the deal
and why are you against it
well we're concerned about the impact
this is going to have in terms of
competition and things like petrol
prices but a big worry is about the
amount of debt that is being heaped on
the Asda business and the long-term
implications that that's got for jobs in
the company and let's not forget we have
tens of thousands of equal pay cases
against Asda we think equal pay is going
to cost the company about 1.5 billion
pounds and given all the debt given this
pretty opaque ownership structure who's
going to be picking up the liabilities
for the money our women members Asda are
due